.
Ich sagte: "Nein, nein, ich nicht."
"Ich werde immer
in der Schweiz sesshaft bleiben."
Es prallen zwei Welten aufeinander.
Das ist nicht immer einfach.
(Englisch) Liebe hält uns zusammen
und treibt uns an.
Wenn ich sie anschaue,
sehe ich pure Liebe.
Ich wusste,
dass ich in einer Woche abreise.
Ich dachte, ich würde nie
nach Ghana zurückkehren.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Forever you and me.
* Pulsieren *
* Melancholische Klaviermelodie *
Dieses Lied schrieb ich,
als ich mir vorstellte,
dass wir nach Ghana ziehen würden -
vor etwa drei oder vier Jahren.
Es heisst "Why you left me".
Es ist ein etwas trauriges Lied.
Obwohl ich mich
auf den Umzug freute.
# It's hard to say goodbye.
# I always knew
# that I am gonna cry
# when I leave you.
# It's hard to say goodbye.
# I always knew
# that I am gonna cry
# when I leave you.
# It's hard to say goodbye
Aus dem Aargau nach Afrika.
Hier in Accra, der Hauptstadt Ghanas,
begann vor 17 Jahren
eine grosse Liebesgeschichte:
Der Schweizer Beda
lernte Mefia kennen.
Sie gründeten eine Familie und
lebten miteinander in der Schweiz.
Vor zwei Jahren stellten sie jedoch
ihr Leben komplett auf den Kopf
und begannen nochmals ganz neu:
hier in Accra.
* "Why you left me" spielt weiter. *
Die Familie zog
an den Stadtrand von Accra,
wo es keine geteerten Strassen
mehr gibt.
Hier verwirklichte Beda seinen Traum:
Er baute ein Kulturzentrum auf.
Ich bin gespannt, wie das aussieht.
Sorry. Thank you.
Hello. Ah!
* Fröhliches Rufen, Lachen *
This is ...
Herzlich willkommen.
- Vielen Dank.
Also ...
- Akwaaba. Das bedeutet willkommen.
Das freut mich.
- Im Team.
Du musst Mefia sein.
- Ja, genau.
Und du bist Mona.
Hey, willkommen. Freut mich.
Das ist ja eine Begrüssung.
Ich freue mich sehr.
- Ich mich auch.
Hey ...
- Ah, schön.
Als ich über diese ungeteerte Strasse
fuhr, fragte ich mich,
wie man auf die Idee kommt, hier
draussen ein Kulturzentrum zu bauen.
Ja, also ...
War das deine oder Bedas Idee?
- Hm ...
Die Idee von uns beiden.
- Von euch beiden.
Okay. Wo ist er?
- Er ist im Studio.
Gehen wir zu ihm?
- Ja, schnell.
Beda macht gerade eine Aufnahme mit
einem bekannten Künstler aus Ghana,
Atongo Zimba.
Sweetheart.
Komm, schau, wer da ist.
Hallo.
- Come and see who is here.
Aha, du bist es.
- Sorry für die Störung.
Darf ich kurz reinkommen? Wir schauen
es uns an. Ich freue mich.
Hallo, ich mich auch.
Jetzt sind wir bereits
in deinem Herzstück.
Ja, genau.
Ihr lebtet zuvor in Dättwil,
in einem kleinen Dorf.
Nun wohnt ihr
in einer Millionenstadt.
Ein totaler Kulturschock, nicht wahr?
- Ähm ...
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Weniger wegen der Anzahl der
Einwohner, sondern ganz generell.
Aber hier in Ashongman
ist es doch ziemlich ländlich.
Es ist nicht direkt im Stadtzentrum.
Ist es das Dättwil von Accra?
- So könnte man es nennen.
Genau.
Darf ich mich etwas umsehen?
- (Beda und Mefia) Ja.
Show me around.
- Los geht's.
Wir haben eine Bar
und ein Restaurant.
Es gibt viel Platz zum Sitzen und
Chillen und wir haben Hotelzimmer.
Macht ihr das zu zweit?
- Wir sind nicht ganz allein.
Wir haben schon ein paar Helfer.
Es werden immer mehr.
Dies ist eines unserer Zimmer.
Wie viele Zimmer habt ihr?
- Zehn.
Zehn?
- Ja.
Und ...
Hier sind die Toilette
und das Badezimmer.
Du bist nun Hotelchefin.
* Mefia lacht. *
Ja.
Wie ist das?
- Barchefin bin ich auch.
Bar- und Restaurantchefin?
- Ja.
Wie ist das für dich?
- Schön.
Ich habe viel zu tun. Das ist gut.
Nichtstun ist nicht so ...
Hattest du in der Schweiz
manchmal zu wenig zu tun?- Ja.
Hast du hier ...
Als die Jungs
in der Schule waren ...
... sass ich manchmal einfach herum,
las oder sah fern.
Oder ich telefonierte
mit meiner Familie.
Beda gab sein sicheres Leben
als Musiklehrer in der Schweiz
auch deshalb auf, um Mefia wieder
ein Lächeln ins Gesicht zu zaubern.
Welcome.
- Good, good, good.
Ich trinke mein Bier.
Okay.
Mein Bruder
hat mir auch eins gebracht.
Er brachte dir eins
und nun ist er dein Bruder?
Und sie meine Schwester.
* Die Frau lacht. *
Unser Zuhause.
Ah, das ist der hintere Teil.
Das ist euer Haus?
Ja.
Seit Sommer 2019
lebt Familie Ehrensperger hier.
So, hier wohnen wir.
* Sie lacht. *
Hier ist das Wohnzimmer,
das Esszimmer ...
... und das Gästezimmer.
Ihr wohnt also
sehr nahe beim Kulturzentrum.
Ja, es ist nicht weit bis dorthin.
Nein.
- Man benötigt 10 Sek.
Es gibt also keine Trennung
zwischen Arbeit und Privatleben?
Nein.
- Es ist alles eins.
Beda studierte
ein Jahr lang in Ghana.
Als Musiker haben es ihm
die afrikanischen Trommeln angetan.
Wenige Tage
vor der Rückreise in die Schweiz
lernte er beim Ausgehen Mefia kennen.
Fürs Küssen braucht es immer zwei,
aber ich glaube, dein Mund
näherte sich eher meinem Mund.
Das glaube ich nicht.
- Das glaubst du nicht?
Nein.
- Ich glaube schon.
Ich weiss es nicht,
aber ich glaube es.
Ihre Familie
gründeten sie im Kanton Aargau.
Vor 15 Jahren kam Levin zur Welt
und vor zehn Jahren Evan.
Die Jungen gingen
im Dorf Dättwil zur Schule.
Hallo.
* Lachen *
Ah, ist das dein Sohn?
- Ja, Levin.
Ah, Levin. Wir haben uns
noch gar nicht ... Ich bin Mona.
Freut mich, hallo.
- Hallo.
Kommst du aus der Schule?
- Ja.
Tut mir leid,
dass wir dich so überfallen.
Im Kanton Aargau
hast du wahrscheinlich nie
eine Schuluniform getragen, was?
Wie war das, als du erfuhrst, dass
du eine Schuluniform tragen musst?
Ich wusste es bereits.
Ah, hier ist noch der Zweite.
* Mefia lacht. *
Ich bin Mona.
Hallo, freut mich.
Du kommst auch aus der Schule.
Was machst du normalerweise,
wenn du nach Hause kommst?
Hausaufgaben, essen ...
... duschen und schlafen.
* Mona lacht. *
Sounds like a plan.
Wie war es für dich, als ihr
aus der Schweiz hierhergezogen seid?
Zogst du gerne hierher?
Nein, anfangs nicht.
- Okay.
Denn hier ist es einfach
total anders als in der Schweiz
und meine Freunde
sind in der Schweiz.
Und jetzt?
- Jetzt habe ich hier auch Freunde.
Und ...
... es ist schöner,
als ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Von der Heimat ihres Vaters
in die Heimat ihrer Mutter:
Das war ein grosser Schritt
für die beiden Jungen.
Ja.
Hallo, spielst du auch mit?
* Hundebellen *
Was ich an ihm am meisten liebe,
ist seine bedingungslose Liebe
zu mir.
Es ist der Wahnsinn,
dass jemand so ...
Ich frage mich manchmal,
ob ich dasselbe für ihn empfinde
wie er für mich.
Ich finde das so ...
Es ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich finde das schön.
Sie ist meine Seelenverwandte.
Sie hat mir wieder gezeigt,
was Liebe ist.
* Langsame Westernklänge *
Brigitte und Jay:
2009 begann ihre Liebesgeschichte.
Für Jay wagte die ehemalige Köchin
in einer Autobahnraststätte
den Sprung über den grossen Teich.
Von Langenthal nach Montana.
Sie war 51.
Vor drei Jahren
lernten wir Brigitte und Jay
und ihre aussergewöhnliche Liebes-
geschichte bei "Hin und weg" kennen.
Jetzt treffen wir sie wieder.
Denn ihre Geschichte
nimmt eine unerwartete Wendung.
Er hatte schon lange
gesundheitliche Probleme.
Das ist seit zehn Jahren
immer wieder ein Thema.
Wir wussten nicht, ob es an seinem
Magen oder seinem Darm liegt.
In den letzten
zwei oder drei Monaten
versuchten die Ärzte herauszufinden,
was das Problem ist.
Erst mit einem speziellen CT-Scan
wurde festgestellt,
dass er einen Tumor im Dünndarm hat.
Am Freitag wurde er operiert und ...
Wir erfahren erst diese Woche,
wie es aussieht,
ob der Tumor gestreut hat oder
ob der Krebs nur lokal begrenzt ist.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Kennengelernt haben sich Brigitte
und Jay auf einer Onlineplattform.
Beide waren geschieden.
Durch die Heirat tauchte Brigitte
in eine neue Welt ein.
Jay ist Native American
und gehört zum Stamm der Nakoda,
der in den Rocky Mountains lebt.
Brigitte ist fasziniert
von dieser komplett anderen Kultur.
* Trommelklänge, Singen *
Bei der Zusammenkunft
von Native Americans,
beim traditionellen Powwow,
tanzte nicht nur Jay mit,
auch Brigitte durfte teilnehmen.
Eine grosse Ehre und ein Zeichen
tiefer gegenseitiger Verbundenheit.
Seit zehn Jahren leben sie
gemeinsam in einem Reservat.
Ein Wohncontainer ist ihr Zuhause.
Auch Jay
lernte Brigittes Heimat kennen.
Er reiste mit ihr in die Schweiz
und traf ihre beiden Töchter
aus erster Ehe.
Brigitte musste sie
in der Schweiz zurücklassen
und vermisst sie jeden Tag.
Hallo. Geht es euch gut?
(Frau) Ja, ganz okay. Und dir?
- Okay.
Auch wegen ihnen trafen Brigitte und
Jay eine tiefgreifende Entscheidung.
Sie wollen in die Schweiz ziehen,
um dort den Rest ihres Lebens
zu verbringen.
Okay, ich habe euch lieb.
Tschüss.
- Einen schönen Tag.
Danke, einen schönen Abend. Tschüss.
* Seufzen *
Ich freue mich schon.
Als ich wegging, dachte ich:
"Sie brauchen mich ja nicht mehr.
Sie sind erwachsen."
Sie waren 18 und 19.
Hier gehen die Kids
in diesem Alter ins College.
In den ersten paar Jahren
klappte es eigentlich gut,
aber plötzlich merkte ich,
dass ich mehr Heimweh habe.
Brigittes Brustkrebserkrankung vor
drei Jahren verstärkte das Heimweh.
Heute geht es ihr
gesundheitlich wieder gut,
aber ihr sei bewusst geworden,
dass ihr nicht mehr ewig Zeit bleibe.
Jetzt will sie in die Schweiz
vorausreisen, um alles vorzubereiten.
Jay kommt später nach.
Das war schon
vor seiner Krankheit so geplant.
Ihre beiden Harleys müssen natürlich
auch in die Schweiz umziehen.
Humor hilft
in dieser aufwühlenden Zeit.
Und auch
die Unterstützung der Familie.
Jays Cousin und seine Tante helfen,
wo sie können.
Der Umzug sei auch für Jay
der richtige Schritt.
Es kommt auf
die innere Einstellung an.
Er wird es schaffen.
Er ist so weit.
Kannst du sie starten?
* Motorbrummen *
Wir lassen sie kurz laufen.
* Nachrichtenton *
Er hat mir
eine Sprachnachricht geschickt.
(Jay) Alles gut bei euch, love bug?
Ja, der Tank ist leer
und mein Motorrad
ist im Transportmodus.
Wir haben's geschafft.
Seine Tante gibt acht,
dass er isst und sich Sorge trägt.
Wir werden ihm aus der ganzen Stadt
Suppen mitbringen.
Aber nichts Scharfes.
Okona, hi, boy.
Hey, boy.
* Sie macht liebevolle Laute. *
Okona bedeutet in der Sprache
der Nakoda der Freundliche.
Der kleine Labrador
macht seinem Namen alle Ehre.
Mit ihm erfüllte sich Jay
einen grossen Wunsch.
Come, give me a hug.
Ich bin traurig.
* Schniefen *
Vielleicht tröstet er auch etwas
über den schwierigen Abschied hinweg.
Ein Lebensabschnitt geht zu Ende.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Wie reagierten unsere Jungs?
Ich glaube, Levin sagte:
"Nein, ich komme nicht mit."
Ja.
- "Ich bleibe bei den Grosseltern."
Bis wir sagten: "In Ghana kriegt ihr
einen Hund und eine Katze."
Sie wollten immer einen Hund
und eine Katze, aber wir sagten:
"In der Schweiz
gibt es keinen Hund."
Bei Familie Ehrensperger
ist unter der Woche früh Tagwache.
* Rattern *
Na, schauen wir, wo sie sind?
Jungs ...
... mögt ihr schon aufstehen?
Du sagtest 4.45 Uhr.
Du musst früh aufstehen, nicht wahr?
Willst du noch liegen bleiben, Evan?
Levin wird um 6 Uhr abgeholt.
Er will jeweils so früh aufstehen.
Manchmal macht er vor der Schule
noch ein paar Hausaufgaben
oder geht irgendwelche Dinge durch.
Ähm, ja ... Dann muss er halt
ziemlich früh aufstehen.
Aber wenn ich
eine lange Nacht hatte,
lege ich mich danach
jeweils wieder hin.
Sie möchten,
dass ich ihnen Äpfel einpacke.
In Ghana gehört
die Schuluniform dazu.
So weiss man gleich,
in welche Schule die Kinder gehen.
Wenn nur der Krawattenknoten
nicht wäre.
Ich kann ihn nicht. Ich konnte dir
mit dem Krawattenknoten nie helfen.
Ich mache das nicht jeden Morgen.
Wenn ich es einmal mache,
reicht das für zwei Wochen.
Ich war zwei Wochen lang im Militär,
aber ich machte es auch nur einmal
und liess es zwei Wochen lang so.
Die beiden Jungs
gehen in eine Privatschule.
Der Unterricht in Englisch
war für den zehnjährigen Evan
eine ziemliche Umstellung.
Es ist schon schwieriger
als in der Schweiz.
In der Schweiz
war ich in der ersten Klasse.
Danach kamen wir hierher.
Da ich nicht gut Englisch konnte,
ging ich hier
auch in die erste Klasse.
Aber bevor das Jahr zu Ende war,
kam ich in die zweite Klasse.
Das ist das Mittagessen für Levin.
Er darf keine Schokolade
oder andere Süssigkeiten
in die Schule mitbringen.
Das ist gut, weil er sich
dadurch gesund ernährt.
* Tiefe Bassklänge *
Tschüss.
- Einen schönen Morgen.
* Tiefe Bassklänge *
Ein Fahrer bringt Levin zur Schule.
In Ghana sind
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel rar
und sie fahren immer erst dann los,
wenn sie voll besetzt sind.
Zoe.
Für Evan gibt es einen Schulbus.
Bis zur Haltestelle
muss er jedoch ein Stück gehen.
In der Schule wird jeden Morgen
die Nationalhymne gesungen.
* Muntere Klänge *
Hello.
- (Frau) How are you?
I'm fine.
* Ruhige Klänge, Krähen eines Hahns *
Da die Temperaturen schon bald
wieder auf 35 °C ansteigen,
sind alle früh auf den Beinen.
Der Unterricht
dauert bis um 15.30 Uhr.
Als sie auf mich zukam, dachte ich:
"Oh, ja."
Schon auf der Heimfahrt sagte ich
zu ihr: "Ich werde dich heiraten."
Sie glaubte mir nicht und sagte:
"Was? Nein, nein."
Ich versuchte, sie zu küssen,
aber sie wich zurück.
"Ah, was läuft?"
Sie sagte: "Das ist zu früh."
Ich fühlte mich etwas überrumpelt.
* Rockballade: "Take my Hand" von
Adrian Stern und Martin Villiger *
Okona, come on. Okona.
Come on.
Come on, boy, fine.
* Brigitte lacht. *
Auch Brigitte und Okona
sind früh unterwegs.
Come on. Ja, fein. Good boy.
Come on, come on.
Good boy.
Yes.
Nice job, thank you.
Heute wird Jay nach seiner Operation
aus dem Spital entlassen
und der Umzugstermin rückt näher.
Jay kommt etwas nach 10 Uhr
nach Hause.
Seine Tante holt ihn ab.
(Seufzend) Ja ...
Es ist alles ein Chaos.
Ich hasse es,
wenn überall Zeug rumsteht.
Naja.
* Rumpeln *
Es ist etwas seltsam,
alles zurückzulassen.
Ein Teil meines Herzens
war immer in der Schweiz
und nun wird es umgekehrt sein.
Ein Teil meines Herzens
wird immer hier sein.
Wenn Brigitte
in die Schweiz vorausreist,
sind sie und Jay
zwei Monate lang getrennt.
Aber dieser Plan geht nur auf,
wenn er sich gut erholt
und keine Komplikationen auftreten.
Ich habe manchmal natürlich Angst,
ihn zu verlieren.
Ich weiss noch nicht ...
Krebs ist so unberechenbar.
* Seufzen *
Ich darf gar nicht daran denken.
Ich muss einfach positiv denken,
sonst falle ich in ein Loch.
Das kann ich
zurzeit nicht gebrauchen.
Tante Charlene bringt Jay
aus dem Spital nach Hause.
Who's there?
- Yeah, I'm home.
Hi, boy.
Hi, sweety.
* Jay stöhnt erleichtert. *
- Hi, baby.
I'm home.
- Good to have you home.
Er muss sich hinlegen.
Er hat starke Schmerzen.
Okay, thank you. Hat er Medikamente
gegen die Schmerzen?
Ich bringe gleich das Rezept.
- Gut, danke.
Das ist typisch für ihn.
Ah, ich kann mich nicht bücken.
* Stöhnen *
Ja, eine besondere Erfahrung.
Jays Ausbildung
als spiritueller Führer hilft ihm,
darauf zu vertrauen,
dass alles gut wird.
Es liegt nicht in unseren Händen.
Spirituell sage ich mir:
"Es ist passiert"
und ich versuche,
damit klarzukommen.
Meine Grosseltern
unterstützen mich und helfen mir.
Der Schöpfer,
Mutter Erde und Vater Himmel -
sie sind alle da und begleiten mich.
Darum mache ich mir
nicht so viele Sorgen.
Ich weiss, dass Brigitte
und viele andere für mich beten.
Look.
Ich habe etwas für dich: Fencheltee.
- Oh, good.
Wir geben ihn den Babys
in der Schweiz gegen Bauchschmerzen.
Bin ich dein Baby?
Du bist mein grosses Baby, ja.
Geht's besser?
- Yeah.
* Er stöhnt. *
Ich sollte etwas essen.
Na du, bist du bei Mami und Papi?
Er passt gar nicht mehr
unter den Stuhl.
Ja, du wirst zu gross.
* Jay lacht. *
Liebe geht nicht nur durch den Magen,
sondern äussert sich auch
durch die Pflege der Haare.
Haare haben eine grosse Bedeutung
in der Kultur der Nakoda.
Für die Krieger waren sie
ein Zeichen der Furchtlosigkeit.
Im Kampf versuchte man,
sie an den Haaren zu packen.
Aber das war uns egal.
Wir waren immer noch
stärker als sie.
* Er lacht. *
Wenn die Haare von jemandem gepflegt
und zu einem schönen Zopf
geflochten sind,
heisst das, dass er jemanden hat,
der sich um ihn kümmert.
Einem Mann die Haare zu pflegen,
ist der Job der Frau.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Fürsorge - auch das ist Liebe.
Vielleicht noch mehr, wenn man älter
und stärker
voneinander abhängig wird.
Mein Kuss?
- Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Dann will ich zwei.
So ist es gut.
- Here you go.
* Seufzen *
(Deutsch) Danke.
- (Deutsch) Bitte schön.
Das muss ich sowieso lernen.
Ja, genau.
(Englisch)
Was ich an dir nicht mag, ist ...
Es gibt nichts,
was du an mir nicht magst.
Manchmal bist du ziemlich stur.
Zu mindestens 80 %
ist mein Weg der beste.
Zu mindestens 80 %.
Ich will ja jetzt nicht streiten.
Wir sind beide etwas stur,
das ist wahr.
We are.
- That's definitely true.
* Asiatische Klänge *
Venice Garden,
so heisst das Quartier in Wuxi.
Die Stadt ist 150 km
von Schanghai entfernt.
* Babyweinen *
Mathias hat Feierabend.
Er arbeitet als leitender Qualitäts-
manager bei einer Schweizer Firma.
Du bist schon da, so früh!
Es hatte nur wenig Verkehr.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, und dir?
Mir auch. Jonathan
ist vielleicht etwas einsam.
Oh, ja, hallo. Hey.
Hey.
Hallo. Papa ist nach Hause gekommen.
Seit ein paar Monaten
sind Sharon und Mathias Eltern.
Jonathan ist
der neue Mittelpunkt ihres Lebens.
Willst du es halten?
Wollen wir es gemeinsam halten?
Es ist prima,
wenn er früher nach Hause kommt.
Wir sehen uns den ganzen Tag nicht.
In den Nächten bin ich bei Jonathan.
Wir brauchen auch unsere Paarzeit.
Willst du noch etwas mehr?
Ganz langsam.
Wenn ich in meinem Umfeld,
z.B. in der Firma,
mit anderen jungen Familienvätern
spreche,
erweckt sich bei mir der Eindruck,
dass sie zwar ein Kind haben wollen,
aber ...
... dass das Wechseln der Windeln
oder das Füttern
eher der Job der Frau
und nicht des Mannes ist.
Noch nie habe ich gesehen,
dass ein chinesischer Mann
Windeln gewechselt hat.
Gib mir die Windel.
Thank you, my darling.
You're welcome. Na?
(Chinesisch)
Okay.
- Okay.
Mathias macht gerade Teig für
Dumplings, gefüllte Teigtaschen.
Die Familie
isst meistens chinesisch -
alles selbstgemacht
und immer mehrere Gerichte.
Eine Hausangestellte
unterstützt Sharon und ihre Mutter.
Wie gross muss er sein?
Mathias ist schon fast ein Profi.
* Sharon lacht. *
Du kannst das besser
als meine Mutter.
Good, eh?
* Alle lachen. *
* Asiatische Klänge *
Was macht die Mama? Na?
* Sharon spricht chinesisch. *
Du schaust zu, was?
Dumplings müssen
gut verschlossen werden.
Wenn sie sich während des Kochens
öffnen, bringe das Unglück.
Er hat wirklich Talent.
- Danke.
Er schliesst sie besser als ich.
Wir arbeiten gut zusammen.
Es gibt keine Konkurrenz.
Eigentlich ist meine Mutter
in Bezug aufs Abendessen die Chefin.
Während des Kochens
streiten wir nicht.
Dieses Foto erinnert an
ein grosses Ereignis vor vier Jahren.
Unsere zivile Trauung.
- Ja.
In China muss man
mit Fingerabdruck bestätigen.
Wie bei einem Vertrag.
Unsere Verlobung war wunderbar.
Aber etwas hat gefehlt.
Ich habe natürlich alles mit meiner
Mutter in der Schweiz besprochen.
Dann dachte ich: "Jetzt
ist es perfekt. Ich muss es tun."
Ich ging also zum Strand.
Zum Glück war er fast leer.
Ein unendlicher Strand.
Mit einem Ast
schrieb ich in den Sand:
"Willst du mich heiraten?"
"Willst du mich heiraten, Babsi?"
So nennt er mich.
"Do you want to marry me?"
- Mit einem Herz.
* Romantische Musik *
Aber etwas hat gefehlt.
Ein Ring.
Eine Verlobung ohne Ring.
Ich war so aufgeregt
und habe alles gegeben.
Aber ich habe alles richtig gemacht
und du hast Ja gesagt.
Everything fine.
- Yes, sure.
Ihre Liebe besiegelten Sharon
und Mathias ein halbes Jahr später
auch noch mit einer traditionellen
chinesischen Hochzeit.
Als wir uns am nächsten Tag trafen,
gingen wir etwas trinken.
Wir bestellten beide eine Cola.
Und ...
... du bezahltest die Cola.
Dass eine Frau meine Cola bezahlt
war mir zuvor in Ghana
noch nie passiert.
So hast du mich gekauft.
Nein, so hast du mich überzeugt -
unter anderem.
* "Why you left me" spielt. *
Im Kulturzentrum ist Beda
für Konzerte und Events zuständig.
Und in jeder freien Minute
macht er selbst Musik.
# It's hard to say goodbye.
# I always knew
# that I am gonna cry
when I leave you.
Mefia managt das Hotel und das
Restaurant mit den fünf Angestellten.
Sie sorgt dafür,
dass alle Probleme gelöst werden,
auch die unangenehmeren.
Wir sind Menschen und machen Fehler.
In einem Hotel
muss man mit allem rechnen.
So etwas kann passieren.
Das macht mir nichts aus.
I'm used to it.
Bezahlt wird,
wie an den meisten Orten in Ghana,
bargeldlos übers Handy.
Mefia überweist dem Handwerker
10 Cedi, gerade mal 1.20 Fr.
Dafür gibt es etwa 1 kg Reis.
Es wird Abend in Accra.
Evan ist Schlagzeuger wie sein Vater.
Zusammen mit Levin dreht er
Videos für seinen Youtube-Kanal.
Sind sie okay?
- Ja.
Und wir sind auf der Suche
nach dem Klub,
in dem sich Mefia und Beda
vor 17 Jahren kennengelernt haben.
Ist es das?
- Ja, ich glaube, das ist es.
Ah, schaut mal,
den alten Namen haben sie übersprayt.
Hier steht es noch.
- Ah, sieht man ihn noch?
"Va...
"Vanity".
Ja, stimmt. Das ist er wirklich.
Was war das für ein Abend?
Jeden Freitagabend ist Ladies Night.
Das ist auch jetzt noch so.
And ladies night means?
(Englisch) Ladys Night bedeutet,
dass Frauen
keinen Eintritt bezahlen.
Und mit wem warst du hier?
Mit meiner Schwester
und drei Freundinnen.
Meine Schwester hatte Geburtstag.
Ah, look. It's open. Ladies night.
(Lachend) Oh, yeah, I want to dance.
- Ja, genau.
Der neue Klubbesitzer
öffnet uns spontan die Tür.
Flashback.
No.
- Du warst hier.
Now you also can ...
You were here.
- Somewhere here.
You were like this.
* Mefia lacht. *
Ich kam rein.
Ich war hier
und du hast dich zu mir gedreht.
Du hast mich angelacht.
Ich kam zu dir
und dann haben wir getanzt.
So hat alles angefangen.
Vor 20 Jahren.
- Vor 17 Jahren.
17 years.
- Ah, okay.
* Mefia lacht. *
Aber dieser Boden war noch nicht da.
Was ist es, das euch zusammenhält?
Wir mögen und lieben einander.
Wir sind wie Magnete,
die einander anziehen.
Es ist erstaunlich,
dass unsere Beziehung hielt.
Wir kannten uns erst seit zehn Tagen
und danach sahen wir uns
zwei Monate lang nicht mehr.
Dann sahen wir uns
wieder für zwei Wochen
und danach drei Monate lang
nicht mehr.
Aber unsere Beziehung
hielt trotzdem.
Ja.
- So ...
Nun waren wir wieder mal hier.
Neun Monate später
machten die beiden Nägel mit Köpfen.
Irgendwann entschieden wir uns,
dass du in die Schweiz kommst.
Wenn du ein Touristenvisum
beantragt hättest,
wäre es wahrscheinlich
abgelehnt worden.
Wenn jemand in die Schweiz
kommen will, muss man ...
... ein Visum zur Vorbereitung
der Heirat beantragen.
Dann gestattet die Schweiz
die Einreise.
Wir hatten ein halbes Jahr Zeit,
um zu heiraten.
Wenn wir nicht geheiratet hätten,
hättest du wieder ausreisen müssen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Mathias und sein Kaderjob
in einer Schweizer Firma.
Was ist das Problem?
Auch nach vielen Jahren bereitet ihm
die chinesische Kritikkultur Mühe.
Alle wollen ihr Gesicht wahren
oder man will verhindern,
dass jemand vor einem Manager
das Gesicht verliert,
und widerspricht ihm daher nicht.
Kulturelle Unterschiede
sind auch zu Hause ein Thema.
Mit der Schwiegermutter
zusammenzuleben, ist hier Tradition,
sorgt jedoch auch für Konfliktstoff.
Sie ist meine Mutter.
In unserer Kultur lassen wir
unsere Eltern nicht allein.
* Freudenschrei *
Brigitte kann endlich wieder
ihre Töchter in die Arme schliessen.
Aber die Freude wird
von der Sorge um Jay überschattet.
Ich hoffe,
dass sich Jay wirklich Sorge trägt,
damit das Ganze gut ausheilt.
Mit Mefia besuchen wir
ihre Familie auf dem Land.
Sie stammt
aus einfachen Verhältnissen,
aber das habe sie nie gestört.
Als ich Beda kennenlernte,
hatte er auch kein Geld.
Ein armer Musiker.
- Ja.
Und wir lernen Andrea kennen.
Sie und ihr Freund in Kolumbien
benötigen zurzeit
viel Durchhaltewille.
So hättest du heiraten wollen?
So werde ich heiraten.
Wann?
- Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe:
Das ist "Hin und weg".
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2022
# Take my hand.